[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Musik]
es zählt das biz wie china sowie kleve
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
aber es ist der flughafen kloten und
einem ort habe man schon ganz viel
emotionale momente erlebt denn wenn sich
die auswanderer von ihren liebsten
verabschiedet
vielleicht wenn dir die zähne begleitung
menschen auf der suche nach einer neuen
heimat und das weil man für ihren mann
am samstagabend in eine große jubiläums
sein muss mit of canada und detail gibt
es wiedersehen mit hermann schönbächler
und co
aber heute habe ich schon mal über
sprachgrenzen will
vielleicht müsse sie das offen davon
dass gibt es nach im welschland wie die
kollegen von rts die verzerrende
packende geschichte die schweizerinnen
und schweizer wie iris glück irgendwo in
der freien event finden spannende
geschichte ausgemacht
[Musik]
familie leipzig ist nach frankreich
gezogen
sie sucht nach einem einfachen
natürlichen leben schon mit nach china
hatte bisoli man in kairo geheiratet
es ist lampen design acht sie ist
erzieherin und autorin und freie müller
träumten von weiten landschaften ihr
abenteuer führte sie bis in den yukon im
hohen norden kanadas
wir hatten diese romans begleitet was
ist aus ihnen geworden
der yukon vor den toren alaskas am rande
von dawson city haben sich aline und
freiheit vor sechs monaten
niedergelassen
sie wollten hier 8000 kilometer von rio
entfernt bot sind schlagen aber die lang
ersehnte arbeitsbewilligung vor denen
nicht erteilt sie waren als touristen
eingereist und dachten es wäre einfach
auch die papiere an ort und stelle zu
bekommen das nein war eine große
enttäuschung denn sie hatten sich schon
gut akklimatisiert
wir finden uns gut zurecht und fühlen
uns wohl hier
schade dass ihr bald wieder gehen müssen
aber sie haben sich damit abgefunden
dass er ehrlich gesagt fehlten mir die
schweiz die freunde und die familie
es wäre wahrscheinlich für mich
schwieriger gewesen zu bleiben es für
sie zu gehen versucht und gesehen dass
es doch noch einen ort auf der welt gibt
der uns gefällt
erbach in diesem jahr sind eher
erwachsene und gemeinsam stärker
geworden und das ist positiv
brüssel sieht sie eine kleine stadt in
der die zeit stehen geblieben ist
ali nun schreit wollten heeren neuer
beruflicher erfahrungen sammeln und ein
ausgewogenes leben führen kommt in
boogie fährst du kommt an die wärme hier
erzählen sie wie dieses abenteuer sie in
den letzten monaten verändert hat wir
haben vieles ausprobiert und haben uns
auf unsere komfortzone heraus gewagt
es tut einfach gut dann hat man schnell
was einem im leben wirklich wichtig ist
man spürt was man will was man nicht
mehr will und wo es einen hinzieht
vorher waren wir nicht wirklich bereit
eine eigene familie zu gründen
aber jetzt beginnen mehreren zu denken
diesbezüglich sind wir ein stück weiter
gekommen
dank dieses abenteuer sind wir das thema
angegangen
in einem monat werden sie familie und
freunde wiedersehen die sie vor einem
jahr verlassen hatten
da kommen erinnerungen hoch und es wird
ihnen bewusst welchen weg sie
zurückgelegt haben
dezember 2016 in alle in der nähe von
poetry ali nun fred organisieren einen
flohmarkt sie lassen alles hinter sich
wir wollen weg weil wir gerne reisen und
neue horizonte entdecken wollen
und wir möchten unseren schweizer
lebensstil verändern dem rechten her an
der natur und viel einfacher leben nach
dem comeback wollen sie in den yukon mal
sehen
bye bye und alles gute danke für alles
gibt sehr viel unbekanntes einen
standort und einen job zu finden ist
schon mal das oberste ziel
danach gehts dann schritt für schritt
voran in montreal müssen sie erst mal
ein auto kaufen
so jetzt haben wir unsere
nummernschilder jetzt können wir uns auf
den weg machen das ist unser auto jetzt
gilt als richtung west gebäck aline und
frei ziehen bei der 28 und seit zwei
jahren verheiratet sie haben ihre
anstellung im handel aufgegeben als
erster sind kanada wartet eine erfahrung
im wald von sacre-coeur für zwei monate
richten sie sich in dieser hütte ein
ohne wasser und elektrizität
solange wir ein dach über dem kopf haben
heizen und alle vier zusammen bleiben
können reicht uns dass das sind alles
erfahrungen
dann entdecken sie die hundezucht bei
der sie sich als freiwillige helfer
engagiert haben
da wird ein traum der jetzt geht's los
nach einem leben mit viel zeitdruck in
der schweiz geniesst das junge paar
diese auszeit
wir genießen es
guten appetit zwei monate später ankunft
im yukon
sie haben sechs provinzen durchquert und
über 5000 kilometer zurückgelegt total
zufrieden note c aber als sie in der
hauptstadt whitehorse einkommen wird ihr
enthusiasmus ein wenig gebremst
wir werden alles unternehmen um eine
arbeit zu finden und hier zu bleiben
aber die stadt an sich motiviert eine
nicht zu sehr zum verweilen ein
dagegen steht ein campingplatz zum
verkauf das interessiert sie aber sie
haben noch immer keine
arbeitsbewilligung ich nehme an ihr seid
schon mit den einwanderungsbehörden in
kontakt wir haben damit begonnen aber es
ist kompliziert habt ihr einen job das
ist das schwierigste
viel glück wir haben wohl geträumt als
wir angekommen sind
wir dachten wir hätten viel geld und
jetzt realisieren wir dass die kanadier
sehr streng sind wenn es um die gründung
eines geschäfts geht die nötigen papiere
fehlen und für white horse schlägt ihr
herz eh nicht sie fahren weiter richtung
norden um für ein langes wochenende
dawson city zu entdecken
schon mal für drei nächte auch während
dieses kurz aufenthaltes versuchen sie
arbeit zu finden
aber der ehemalige direktor eines
hiesigen hotels ermutigt sie nicht
gerade unsere träume schwinden nur so
dahin
ich glaube nicht dass wir es schaffen
werden doch doch zwei monate später sind
sie noch immer am selben ort raus jetzt
fühlen wir uns wohl her und könnten uns
vorstellen langfristig zu bleiben
es geht uns gut inzwischen haben sie die
arbeitsbewilligung beantragt durch die
antwort lässt auf sich warten und ihr
visum läuft bald ab
wir verlängern unser touristenvisum bis
wir die arbeitsbewilligung bekommen
sie wollen daran glauben ihr traum ist
ein leben im yukon
das ist hilft ja sehr schön wir träumen
immer noch von unserer hütte in kanada
aber uns ist bewusst geworden dass das
leben weit ab von allem doch sehr hart
ist man ist isoliert muss sich
durchschlagen und es ist schwierig
völlig autonom zu sein
wir müssen das schritt für schritt
aufbauen und möchten es ausprobieren
wir bereuen überhaupt nichts nichts was
sie anders machen würden wir würden es
wieder genauso machen
wir haben vielleicht die schwierigkeiten
unterschätzt eine arbeitsbewilligung zu
erhalten
es ist ein langes kompliziertes
verfahren dass wir besser von zu hause
aus erledigt hätten
wir hätten im voraus wissen müssen wo
wir uns niederlassen und in welchem
bereich wir arbeiten wollten
das alles galt es für uns erst mal zu
entdecken
prof
kairo eine der größten städte der welt
hier hat sich jean luc niedergelassen
vor einem jahr hat er die ägypterin
agiere geheiratet
sie haben sich vor vier jahren
kennengelernt
seither gab es viel hin und her zwischen
lausanne und kairo so legte der nahen
osten schon ziemlich gut aber hier zu
leben ist noch mal was anderes
alles ist völlig anders
ein totaler kontrast zum alltag in der
schweiz
es ist schwierig sich an diesen
lebensrhythmus anzupassen
in der schweiz steht man früh auf hier
beginnt der tag ab 12 uhr mittags und
endet um mitternacht
bei den behörden habe ich eine
niederlassung in ägypten geld er aber
nicht als ägypter er darf zwar ihr leben
aber noch nicht arbeiten
das ist von den nachbarn sehr heiß dann
essen wir etwas später in ihrer wohnung
hat sich sony kein eigenes atelier
eingerichtet
ich habe eine lampe entwickelt die wie
ein ägyptisches prot aussieht die form
gefiel mir ich habe sie kopiert und so
ist die lampe entstanden
er experimentiert und entwickelt
originelle modelle
das ist meine experimentier waren wo ich
verschiedene prototypen entwickelt habe
jetzt ist es mir gelungen die letzte
version fertig zu stellen um eine serie
zu produzieren
das hier ist eine version mit xtext er
hofft dass er mit der produktion bald
beginnen kann um wieder etwas zu
verdienen
seit über einem jahr lebt er von seinen
ersparnissen finanziell war es ein
schwieriges jahr weil wir nur geld
ausgegeben haben
wir hoffen dass sich die situation im
nächsten jahr stabilisieren wird
und wieder geld in die kasse fließt das
muss einfach passieren
ich hoffe von diesem lampen projekte
einige zeit leben zu können
seine beruflichen kontakte hat er
inzwischen ausgebaut damit begonnen
hatte er schon als er noch in der
schweiz wohnte
[Musik]
vor zwei jahren in osaka lag 41 will die
schweiz verlassen um sich in ägypten
niederzulassen und dort seine verlobte
zu heiraten
oft sind sie in kontakt per skype ich
bin ungeduldig und warte auf dich zurück
arbeitet halbtags als sozial animateur
in einem gefängnis aber register auch
videofilme und ein leidenschaftlicher
lampen designer
ich habe viele prototypen gemacht so und
jetzt gehe ich nach ägypten um andere
lampen zu fabrizieren mal sehen bevor er
ins land der pyramiden fliegt feiert er
noch weihnachten mit seiner familie
frohe weihnachten ich bin ein bisschen
traurig es ist schon schwer die familie
zu verlassen ich denke das ist das
schwierigste aber seine entscheidung
steht fest er will in ägypten leben und
abi heiraten
sie haben sich dank eines pro helvetia
projektes in kairo kennengelernt aber
wie 37 und möchte in ihrem land weiter
arbeiten
ich konnte mein traum nicht
verwirklichen wenn ich in die schweiz
ziehen würde
und so nehmen sie die heirats
formalitäten in angriff ein behörden
marathon mit vielen hindernissen
unmöglich das problem ist das fehlende
geburtsurkunde ja das ist schon ein
ziemlicher stress
sie werden sich mehrere monate gedulden
müssen
wir wollten heiraten und dachten nicht
dass dies so viele probleme mit sich
bringen würde
hoffen wir dass es klappt in der
zwischenzeit machen sie sich auf
wohnungssuche in maadi ihrem lieblings
quartier das ist eine schöne
überraschung das fängt gut an
das lässt ihre herzen höher schlagen und
agiert hätte hier genügend platz für
ihre yoga stunden
ich liebe darf wunderbar so weil sie
eingerichtet sind kanadier ihrer
lieblingsbeschäftigung nachgehen
sie unterrichtet mehrmals wöchentlich
bei sich zu hause
es ist toll jeden tag ich liebe das
unglück besucht mehrere handwerker guten
tag im herzen von kairo entdeckte einen
lampen fabrikanten
das ist wunderschön wirklich wunderschön
ich gratuliere
sobald ich etwas besser arabisch spreche
werde ich mit ihm zusammen arbeiten um
eine lampe zu entwickeln
auch diese werkstatt eines befreundeten
altwarenhändler besucht so league
regelmäßig zu dem sie inspirieren mich
danke der waadtländer entwickelte auch
projekte für terre des hommes und pro
helvetia hat ihn mit der animation eines
ateliers an der kairoer oper beauftragt
großer softie der ort her ist
faszinierend es ist beeindruckend
noch am selben abend erfährt er dass ein
workshop gestrichen wird die behörden
haben in trainiert und ihn abgesagt ohne
weitere erklärungen
in ägypten kann sich alles von heute auf
morgen ändern
man denkt man hätte heute etwas erreicht
und morgen ist es nicht mehr so bis
heute hat sich nichts verändert meine
projekte haben mich viel energie und
zeit gekostet
der alltag braucht viel zeit und von
heute auf morgen ist alles blockiert das
ist schon schwierig wenn man hier ist
muss man dieses risiko akzeptieren
wir sind beide künstler ein projekt
kommt zustande ein anderes nicht für
mich ist das kein misserfolg
nein ich nenne es nicht misserfolg man
lernt ja während dem ganzen prozess und
natürlich arbeitet man immer sehr hart
um erfolg zu haben
derzeit beginnt bei den leipzigs in der
road gewonnen
heute ist die familie vollzählig
normalerweise geht justine bei
tagesanbruch zur arbeit aber den
heutigen morgen verbringt sie daheim
wenn ich arbeiten gehe ist es noch
nachts den sonnenaufgang sehe ich nicht
dafür die sterne und den mond und das
ist wirklich schön
vor drei jahren haben sie nun genau ihr
leben radikal verändert
seither leben sie gemäss ihren
wunschvorstellungen in harmonie mit der
natur und den tieren gar nicht mini für
tanja hier soll ich zwei geben einen
halt sehr fest trotzdem siehst du sie
wollen unter umweltgerechten bedingungen
züchten und es ist ihnen sehr wichtig
welche rassen sie dazu auswählen
die hof produkte dienen in erster linie
der selbstversorgung aber sie haben auch
begonnen welche zu verkaufen
wir haben schon länger verkauft und
hasen
wir haben auch abonnenten die
wöchentliche holen was ist mir natürlich
brauchen wir einen großteil selbst
aktive brasil hauptaktivität die wir
ausbauen wollen ist die schweinezucht
[Musik]
das ist sexy ist ein huhn
wenn er war früher verkaufschef und
seine frau system krankenschwester sie
haben den schweizer komfort verlassen um
im einklang mit ihren tiefen sehnsüchten
zu leben
[Musik]
zu tisch wir frühstücken nicht oft alle
vier zusammen
deshalb genießen wir sehr uns am
wochenende dafür zeit zu nehmen
wer möchte was trotz der entfernung zu
ihren familien würden sie ihre
entscheidung nicht rückgängig machen zu
ihrer kleinen heute morgen müssen wir
eier ausliefern zusammen betrachten sie
ihren sprung ins ungewisse ende 2014 in
frankreich legen jazz den unzählige
kilometer zurück um die kinder zur
schule zu bringen oder zum grundstück zu
fahren dass sie gekauft haben
es sind 18 hektaren es wird bestimmt
jahre dauern bis es hier so aussieht wie
wir es uns erträumt haben denn momentan
gibt es hier nur gras und wir möchten
dass es üblich bewachsen wird aber es
ist schon ein riesen schritt zu wissen
dass wir einen ort haben wo wir machen
können was wir wollen ausprobieren und
uns ein stück weit von unserem eigenen
land ernähren also ich schon mal ganz
toll
[Musik]
im januar 2015 beginnen die leipzigs
ihre jurte zu bauen
es ist ein wunderbares gefühl von
freiheit
[Musik]
ich denke es gibt einem auch eine andere
beziehung zu seiner behausung
wir wissen noch nicht genau was wir
machen werden aber die toiletten werden
draußen installiert das habe am anfang
wird gebastelt aber mit der zeit werden
wir die einrichtungen verbessern
etwas macht ihnen allerdings probleme
der boden anfangs wollten sie einfach
fahren wachsen lassen haben sich aber
umentschieden
das sind erfahren interessierte uns und
wir wollten die idee nicht gleich
verwerfen
auch wenn sie verrückt und unpraktisch
clásico coutinho
aber jetzt haben wir uns für einen
holzboden entschieden wir sind gut
vorwärts gekommen aber wir dachten nicht
dass es so viel zeit braucht das kommt
davon dass wir uns nicht auskennen das
ergebnis lässt sich sehen denn sie
scheuen keine mühe die vier leben
inzwischen auf 40 quadratmetern
wir fühlen uns sehr wohl hier präsent
platz angeht kommen wir gut zurecht das
wieso aber es wird bestimmt momente
geben während denen es zu eng wird aber
wir leben ja vor allem im freien und das
hilft sogar abgewaschen wird im freien
jedenfalls sehen wir im einklang
ich meine wir sind nicht hin und
hergerissen zwischen unseren
überzeugungen und dem was wir leben
es entspricht unsere sensibilität die
familie verbringt mehr zeit zusammen als
in ihrem früheren leben kommen gern
hierher ja eure freunde kommen gern
wegen der tiere früher sagt sie gar
nicht ich fuhr frühmorgens los im kern
spät abends heim
das ist jetzt völlig anders wir haben
lebensqualität gewonnen
es ist toll zu sehen dass wir aus einem
ort wo nichts war etwas gemacht haben
man schaut gern zurück aber natürlich
bleibt noch viel zu tun
wir genießen den gegensatz zu unseren
früheren leben in der schweiz
dort schien mir der rhythmus stressiger
wenn man die anzahl stunden zählt
arbeite ich hier vielleicht mehr
aber uns gefällt die atmosphäre hier das
hatten wir in der schweiz nicht und ich
genieße das auch weiterhin baumgartner
presse
in dieser legendären region der
goldgräber haben die jurassier freude am
qualm entdeckt diese neue
freizeitbeschäftigung beschert ihnen
neuer emotionen
das ist super zum glück kennen wir viele
leute und wir haben einen freund der uns
von zeit zu zeit seinen quarters leid es
ist toll sich damit im schnee zu
amüsieren
im gegensatz zum schlamm im sommer
im modell treffen sie ihre freunde
wieder hallo wie geht's uns denn seit
beginn der großen kälte ist grillen und
goldwaschen im fluss nicht mehr angesagt
wir sind kaum aus dem campinggelände
raus gekommen weil wir uns viel zeit
füreinander genommen haben
da wir seit diesem sommer wussten dass
wir wieder heim müssen sehen wir in
unserem eckchen geblieben dadurch
hielten sich auch ihre ausgaben in
grenzen und sie kommen finanziell gut
über die runden
wir haben uns gut durchgeschlagen
es funktioniert wenn man gern da und
dort zu packt er wird viel getauscht das
waren schon sehr günstige ferien zum
ausleihen dann hatten sie 40 tausend
franken gespart und nach hause fliegen
sie nicht mit leeren händen
wir haben nur etwa die hälfte unseres
budgets aufgebracht das ist nicht
schlecht
ja das ist mehr als vernünftig hast du
zu viel
ja das ist so
im südwesten frankreichs lässt der
familienalltag jedem viel freiheit jedes
kind hat inzwischen oben sein kleines
nest unsere neuen betten und die älteren
schlafen im wohnwagen seit zwei tagen
zieht ihr kätzchen alle aufmerksamkeit
auf sich
also was ist mit der katze frisst sie
eine riesenportion gegeben sie wird
nicht lange da wir von mäusen geplagt
sind brauchen wir eine katze ich hole
mal die schubkarre aus dem garten
gartenarbeit ist für justine eine quelle
der persönlichen entfaltung und der ruhe
sie schwört auf permakultur dieses jahr
ist alles sehr gut gedient
das ist motivierend es war wirklich cool
das ziel ist nicht total autonom zu sein
sondern mehr bezug zu haben zu dem was
man isst wir möchten näher an der quelle
unserer nahrungsmittel seien
es ist ein besseres gefühl den ganzen
zyklus mitzuerleben
diesen nachmittag während ein spezielles
ereignis vorbereitet ein lamm soll
geschlachtet werden nur kontrolliert den
kühlschrank um später das fleisch darin
abzuhängen
das ist das wichtigste ereignis bei uns
auf dem hof und wir müssen uns immer
darauf vorbereiten
sevilla ist das nicht einfach
deshalb hält sie lieber etwas distanz
nachdem sie sich einige zeit in die usa
zurückgezogen haben
gehen sie zur erde aber auch nur im
möchte auf distanz bleiben
[Musik]
bis zum schluss sorgen sie dafür dass
das tier gut und respektvoll behandelt
wird es ist kein belangloser akt einem
tier das leben zu nehmen
aber es gehört zu unserem ansatz
möglichst autonom zu werden
für mich ist es eine sehr
außergewöhnlicher moment und meiner
meinung nach sollte das nur gelegentlich
stattfinden
damit man dem wahren sinn dieses aktes
gerecht wird
dann wird das fell abgezogen und das
fleisch zerlegt die haut und etwa 20
kilo fleisch behalten sie für den
eigenbedarf
kairo was machst du da ein bier
verbringt die meiste zeit mit schreiben
sie ist autorin von verschiedenen
drehbüchern für fernsehserien
ich habe neue projekte noch nichts
konkretes aber ernsthafte gespräche rund
um eine serie über den ramadan
sie ist auch erzählerin und gibt
englisch und theaterkurse gleichzeitig
geht sie ihre anderen leidenschaft nach
die meisten teilnehmer sind ausländer
und sie sind im moment nicht in ägypten
aber ja ich gebe in diesem raum immer
noch meine yogastunden unterdessen ist
jean luc in einem verbleibe ein nach art
labor fabrik in der nähe ihrer wohnung
gehört hier zu den stammgästen mohammed
wie geht es dir
das ist wirklich das atelier von dem ich
geträumt habe
wo zusammenarbeit möglich ist und wo mir
mohammed sein projekt erklären kann
teambuilding
hier werde ich den 3d drucker benutzen
den brauche ich um meine lampen
herzustellen
der vorteil ist dass diese maschinen
hochpräzise sind danach habe ich gesucht
präzision ist alles ziemlich
schweizerisch
momentan darf noch nicht erarbeiten
deshalb mache ich recherchen und
entwickler im projekt aber resident
natürlich auch an die nächsten etappen
herstellung und verkauf der lampen
ich muss die richtigen personen finden
auf die ich mich verlassen kann
das ist nicht einfach hat ein diplom der
kunst und designschule in genf und
schätzt hier die anregung und kompetenz
dieses quartier kennt ja gut er hat hier
seine adressen und hat schon einige
bekanntschaften gemacht
danke er fühlt sich hier wohl
aber ich muss dranbleiben an gewissen
tagen geht es wunderbar und ich bin
super positiv von anderen ist es
schwieriger war in alltägliche probleme
lösen muss
es gibt viel unvorhergesehenes also ist
es ein ziemliches auf und ab wir
vertrauen auf die zukunft das müssen wir
weit weg vom land der pharaonen eine
vase in den südlichen pyrenäen
da müssen wir aber viel werben ja das
ist viel arbeit
justine erkundet gern alle facetten des
landlebens
sie ist neugierig unternehmungslustig
und scheut sich nicht vor neuen
erfahrungen was ich an unserem projekt
am meisten schätze ist mehr selber zu
machen
häufig geht es daneben und man ist etwas
entmutigt aber dann versucht man es auf
einem anderen weg aber ich liebe den
moment wo man es geschafft hat etwas
selber zu machen
januar hingegen ist zum spezialisten für
zäune geworden
langsam haben wir durch fixen gehege
das sind holzpfähle mit gittern oder
elektrischen grad
das sollte die nächsten 30 jahre halten
das ist meditativ weil sich alles
wiederholt repetitive
familie leipzig lebt nur mit einem lohn
justine arbeitet 70 prozent in einem
medizinischen labor
finanziell ist es schwierig
ich verdiene 1000 euro
das deckt wirklich nur die festen posten
sobald eine zusätzliche rechnung kommt
wird es kompliziert aber wir nur und ich
vertrauen darauf dass es uns an nichts
fehlen wird und dass wir immer genug zum
leben haben werden und es ist auch eine
lebensschule denn wenn man weniger ist
tauchen neue ressourcen auf
im yukon haben die beiden jura cia eine
neue aktivität entdeckt wir haben ein
feature set für anfänger gekauft für
fischer die keine ahnung haben
das stinkt das wird schon gehen
sie haben gefallen an diesem hobby
gefunden fischen ist auch im jura
beliebt wir haben freunde die fischen
vor allem einen also haben wir
vorgesehen ein paar fischer tage bei uns
zu organisieren
man stellt die angelrute auf und das
bier daneben und wartet bis sie anbeißen
es ist weniger sportlich als hier aber
auch angenehm
für die beiden wichtiger ist die anzahl
fische sind die gefühle die ihn dieser
wunderbaren landschaft aufkommen
in kairo besuchen abonji league
regelmäßig den quartier markt der
waadtländer musste sich an die
willkürlichen preise gewöhnen
15 ich zahle 15 weil man man ausländer
ist er sagt 15 nein höchstens 12 schauen
wir bedienen uns und schauen
die inflation ist aber auch realität
die preise steigen und die leute sind
besorgt trotz allem bewundert stück das
angebot auf den regalen
in ägypten liebt es super früchte und
gemüse
man kann wirklich sagen ein geschenk des
nils hier findet man sehr frische und
sehr reife früchte
im gegensatz zu europa im alltag kommt
mit der sprache zurecht aber er muss
seine arabischkenntnisse noch verbessern
zwei mal pro woche geht er in die
gemeindebibliothek seines quartiers zum
unterricht willkommen
platz bitte wie geht es heute mit einem
arabisch sehr gut sehr gut und da der
arbeit wie kommst du voran
es wird schwierig können wir das
alphabet machen du machst das hier gut
schon gucken weil du sehr effizient und
geduldig mit mir bist danke jean-luc
gibt sich mühe voranzukommen er ist sich
bewusst dass die sprache der schlüssel
zur integration sein wird
in der not geboren findet der unterricht
seit einem jahr zu hause statt
wer kümmert sich morgens um die kinder
justine am nachmittag selbst das
zusammen so gut wie null ab hier ist
unsere priorität in der erziehung
abgesehen vom fortschritt ist vor allem
die lust am lernen
ich denke die kinder haben einen großen
wissensdrang und den wollen wir nicht
zerstören
sie haben ein festes programm passen
dieses aber der lust und laune der
kinder an
ich habe ihnen vorgeschlagen einen
morgen lang einfach allein zu lernen und
sie haben sich für chinesisch
entschieden
das war eines der fächer dass du auswahl
stand es gibt eine spedition elia ist
gerade am chinesisch lernen
[Musik]
im allgemeinen sind wir alle sehr froh
mit diesem system und es passt zu
unserer lebensweise
[Applaus]
in ägypten wird heute ein großes fest
vorbereitet etwa eine autostunde von der
hauptstadt entfernt erblüht sind schon
seit einem jahr verheiratet ähnlich
wollen sie mit freunden feiern
[Applaus]
für radierung jean-luc nimmt das leben
hier schritt für schritt neue formen an
sie glauben an ihrer beruflichen
projekte aber auch ein privates glück
man wünscht uns viel erfolg für unsere
projekte und unser leben und eine große
familie mit sechs kindern
da hätte er eine 20 jährige heiraten
sollen
in frankreich haben auch justine und
träume und projekte das wichtigste ist
ein kleiner schuppen für die
landwirtschaft
der schuppen soll als trocknungs raum
und zum direktverkauf der produkte
verwendet werden um ihn zu bauen haben
sie eine finanzierungs kampagne lanciert
in den vier jahren haben sie ihren weg
gefunden und bereue nichts
es ist okay für mich wenn es so
weitergeht solange wir uns im moment mit
der familie und den leuten um uns herum
wohl fühlen ist es richtig so für mich
ist die bilanz jedenfalls sehr positiv
für mich auch es ist ein schönes
abenteuer sich gemeinsam zu entwickeln
und zu viert vorwärts zu kommen
hier haben wir dieses schöne land als
grundlage dafür
für alle in unfreiheit ist der traum von
einem neuen leben in kanada ausgeträumt
nach einem spannenden jahr nehmen sie es
aber gelassen
die dinge kann man anders als geplant
aber jetzt wissen wir es die frage ob
unser leben in der schweiz oder hier
stattfinden wird und ob es woanders
besser ist steht nicht mehr im raum
das ist unsere erfahrung
sie haben das abenteuer gewagt wie
tausende von schweizern die zu neuen
horizonten aufbrechen immer auf der
suche nach dem glück
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und fonds